[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUS CLASS: Hello world, and
welcome to this week's episode
of Google+ Developers Live.
Today we're going to talking
about the Sign-In user
experience and ways that you
can make the most of the
available features
from Google+.
So I'm Gus Class.
I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer on Google+.
And I'm here today to kind of
again, elaborate on that topic
that Joanna Smith and I were
talking about this year at
I/O. [INAUDIBLE]
sign-in on your site is to get
that user signed in and
connected on your site.
MALE SPEAKER: I'm sorry, we're
going to have start this
again, [INAUDIBLE].
We're going to persevere.
GUS CLASS: We're going
to persevere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUS CLASS: Hello world.
And welcome to this
week's episode of
Google+ Developers Live.
I'm Gus Class, a Developer
Programs Engineer on the
Google+ team.
And earlier this year Joanna
Smith and I gave a talk at I/O
on best practices for
Google+ Sign-In.
We're going to cover one of
those concepts today, and this
is reflecting the user back and
welcoming them when they
sign in to your site.
So as a foundational thing about
Google+ Sign-In, the
goal when you integrate is to
get that user to sign in to
your site and then become
connected to your site in a
way that they build an
emotional connection.
So what I'm going to do today
is, I'm going to start with a
very basic site.
And then I'm going to make
marginal improvements on that
Sign-In experience to show you
ways that you can be creative
and create a more engaging
experience.
So if you look at my screen,
here is the basic site.
On the top right hand corner of
the site, which is one of
the hot spots for where users
look when they see your site
the first time, is the Google+
Sign-In button.
And on the top left, I invite
the user to sign in.
So let's take a look at just
the basic scaffolding that
we're building from here and
look at that code behind the
site that's relevant.
So here is that index.html
markup.
And if you look inside of here,
this is a very basic
sign in button.
I'm connecting that sign in
button to the global call
back, which is called out as
onSignincallback, and then
from within that global call
back, I'm connecting the user
to a helper module which
contains the functionality for
doing things like rendering
the user experience.
So if you just look here
inside of that
onSignincallback, what I'm doing
is I'm just hiding the
Sign In button, rendering a
Disconnect button, and then
kind of connecting that
user with that
helper.connect method.
And actually, sorry, what I
meant to say was inside of
helper.connect is where we're
going to render the various
user experience or
for that sign in.
So let's go back to the site.
And let's see what happens when
I sign in the first time.
So here you have this
site again.
There's lots of cute pictures
of puppies on here, and that
user is invited to sign in so
that they can do all of the
great things that they
can do once they're
signed in to the site.
So I'll click Sign In, and the
Google Sign-In authorization
dialogue should render.
We'll see what happens
before that happens.
So it looks like we're having
some connectivity issues here,
no big deal.
Go back and there it goes.
So here's that authorization
dialogue that you've become
very familiar with because
you're Google+ Developers.
And so inside of this
authorization dialogue you can
see the various things that
Google is requesting for on
the top and the various things
that will become publicly
available from the
user's friends.
So I'll just sign in here.
And once I sign in, something
is going to
happen on the site.
And that something that happens
is really what we're
going to focus on today.
So in this really basic example,
what we are doing is,
we hide the Sign In button.
We render a Disconnect button.
And then we reflect the user's
display name back to them--
indicating to them, oh,
you're signed in now.
So this is a real basic
implementation.
And so we're not doing
anything special yet.
But this is a good start.
So let's take a look at
how I'm doing this.
So I'll go back in here.
Let's look at some code.
And so here's that
basic example.
You'll notice that I'm using
jQuery, jQuery UI.
You can do this anyway
you like.
A lot of people are talking
about various ways of just
kind of using raw JavaScript
and CSS referencing.
It doesn't really matter.
But the point here is the things
that are happening.
So on the top here you can see
where I hide the various
things that are going
to be updated.
And then you can see where I
render that signed in as the
current user.
And then you can see where I
show the Disconnect button and
then show the Authorization
button.
So what happens here is, after
that user signs in, that Sign
In button disappears and then
a Disconnect button appears.
And that user profile
appears again.
So let's go back and look at
that Disconnect button.
So what I've done is I've just
kind of tried to do something
cute here, sort of match
the theme of my site.
And I've added this little
Disconnect button.
When you click Disconnect, the
user is prompted with a
disconnect dialogue.
And then the user, after they
click Disconnect, they break
up with the site.
And then they're disconnected.
So there's that basic
experience.
Let's think about ways that we
can make it even better.
So if you're following here,
you'll notice also that this
is actually a live site.
So if you want to check this
out on your own, you're
welcome to look at
my code directly.
But moving along, here is
a better experience.
So I'll just reload this
page to make sure
that it's all good.
And so here's that same
experience that
the developers sees.
The Sign In button in that
hot spot, in the
top right hand corner.
And then the user signs in.
And after you sign
in, something
different is going to happen.
That user's profile information,
their picture
which is extracted from their
Google+ profile, is then
displayed alongside
their name.
And then that same experience
from before happens.
So let's again revisit that code
and see what we're doing
differently.
So the key point that I want you
to take away from the code
that I'm showing you here is
that the differences between
an awesome experience and a
real basic experience is
almost trivial.
You don't have to do very much
more to create a more engaging
experience.
So looking at the code here,
the big change that happens
now is that HTML, as opposed to
being rendered just based
on the user's display name, is
being created using this
getProfileHTML function.
So you'll notice that the first
thing that we do is, we
get that user's image URL.
And that image URL will then be
put inside of that profile
box along with alt text
displaying their display name.
And then that user's display
name again is going to be
reflected back to the user.
So something special happens
when the user sees themselves
looking back on the site.
They think to themselves, I
am part of this site now.
My experience is
tailored to me.
And now, like that social
connection is made there.
So that if other people exist
on that site, or if you're
building these connections with
other people on the site,
then you know that it's
a face-to-face sort of
conversation and experience.
So I'm going to show
you one more way
you can make it better.
I'll just disconnect
here again.
Reload the page, and I'm just
using these anchor tags to
kind of distinguish between
the various experiences.
So I'll sign in.
And after that sign
in, something
different is going to happen.
You might have missed it, but on
the top left hand corner of
the site, my profile
was rendered.
And then it bounces.
So let's take one more
look at that.
Awesome.
So you see that profile bounce,
and then all of a
sudden your attention is
drawn right to it.
Now I'm not going to say that
this is what you should do
specifically for your site.
But this is one unique way that
you can kind of enhance
that experience, draw the
user in more, and
let them know that--
yeah.
I'm signed in to this site.
I'm there and here's
my information.
Here is the information that
Google is presenting to me.
And now I'm kind part of
this site's experience.
So this is going to be the
final code snippet
that I'll show you.
And again, this is just a very
small change to that code that
we had seen as our
basic example.
So what we're doing differently
here is, we're
using a jQuery UI effect
for bounce.
And we're setting a time out
for that animation to show.
So that's pretty much it.
The real key takeaway here is,
try to be creative in the way
that you're integrating
Google+ Sign-In.
And think about the things
that you can do that are
unique to your site to
distinguish it from just sort
of that boring old or
conventional sign in
experience where just the user
signs, they're authorized on
your site, and that's it.
So think about ways
that you can make
your experience better.
And keep an eye out for future
Google+ GDLs, because we're
going to be showing additional
things you can do to improve
your site experience.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]